on ne recensait 1337 nouveau 4e ville
hier en chine un chiffre très bas selon
nos standards mais qui a suffi à
convaincre les responsables chinois de
confiner 17 millions d'habitants de
shenzhen et d'imposer des restrictions
dans une dizaine d'autres villes
depuis le début de la pandémie la chine
appliqué avec succès sa politique de
tolérance zéro à l'aco vides mais avec
au micro le défi est immense se donnant
à fond
mais pas un concert laver sans chine en
europe de l'ouest on donne du lest
aujourd'hui en france presque toutes les
barrières ont sauté oui on respire et on
sent les choses ce qui on le sentait
plus de placer papa oui
on voit les sourires et c'est plus
agréable de travailler son masque mais
il ya un revers au relâchement des
mesures senneterre après débat
significative du nombre de cas en
février on observe maintenant une hausse
dans une demi-douzaine de pays parfois
accompagnée d'une augmentation des
hospitalisations
la montée en force du soutien bea points
2 pourrait aussi expliquer ce phénomène
des certainement lui qui a pris d'assaut
ces pays hors europe et donc et on sait
qu'il est rare au moins 30 pour simple
strass necib que le celui qu'on nomme le
baril me croque et puis il y a les
vaccins on le sait même les meilleurs
ont montré leurs limites et la troisième
raison évidemment c'est la baisse de la
protection vaccinale qu'on a dit c'est
quasiment une constante qu'on voit avec
ces vaccins l'ol ce virus l'ocs en
théorie disent les spécialistes
cette remontée en europe pourraient se
transpose en amérique comme ça a été le
cas durant les vagues précédentes
au québec comme ailleurs je crois qu'on
devrait plutôt attend de voir un peu ce
qui se passe en europe est de savoir un
peu plus ce qui se passe ici avant
d'annoncer clairement si oui en fait on
retire le masque en ce moment moins de
10 % des nouveaux cas de coved au québec
sont liés ou sous verrière bea points 2
his normand grondin radio canada
montréal